David asks Instagram seems great for
jabs but not for right hooks any ideas
or predictions on using it to make right
hooks David there's an interesting thing
here and I want to go I'm gonna go deep
today because I got just got whiff of
the questions and so this could be a
very deep episode a deep and deep
episode I said it twice deep and deep
episode of the askgaryvee show is coming
guys so like a lot of you have left in
the comments like I like when you get
very detailed I'm getting detailed today
let's get into it first you have to
debate the philosophy of a holistic
social media approach up shouldn't you
just use Instagram as a jabbing platform
by itself should Instagram be a place
where you're jabbing because you also
know a lot of your fans follow you on
Twitter and Facebook and things of that
nature and a lot of times I mean look I
use Instagram as jabbing for the first
couple years a lot of selfies a lot of
sneaker shots right but if you've
noticed with the askgaryvee show I'm
using Instagram as a right hug platform
lately if you look by percentage over my
last 15 to 25 photos as a matter of fact
lately I've tried to throw some more
jabs in because I felt there was a
little too much right hook going on I'm
now putting up 15-second versions of
this episode and in the copy saying go
into my profile because in my profile
I'm linking to the current episode so
the only way to actually drive people
out of Instagram is by changing your URL
in the edit profile part of your profile
and so that's the way to throw a right
hook and so yes you could put a piece of
creative on Instagram that works and
then in the copy drive people that see
that into your profile and then link out
and convert your right hook as driving
them there and so I've done both though
I for a long time and still probably at
this point it's why I'm testing I'm
always going against my own stuff all of
you could call me on say Gary didn't you
say not to do that and thank you I'm
always going against my own POVs to
always taste right now I'm not sure
exactly where it fit but like
intuitively I'm feeling that the jabbing
on Instagram is a great way to go so if
you look at your whole thing as a
holistic play and you're on all these
platforms and your core group is
following you in multiple places maybe
Instagram is where you're jabbing maybe
Facebook is where you're throwing that
right hook so that's the deep
put steak on the bone today answer to
that one